we welcome you back inside city field
for game two of this doubleheader
between the mets and the marlins they
try to rebound in game number two with
seth lugo getting his first start in
over two years he will be opposed by the
rookie trevor rogers making his major
league debut
so what do you say we meet trevor rogers
shall we this is a guy that we've heard
about for quite some time for the
marlins the 13th overall pick by the
marlins in 2017
big ol lefty big old arm and a sub three
era jd davis two for four in the opener
one two from
rogers and there it is his first major
league strikeout
goes up the ladder at 96 miles an hour
now michael conforto home with a 2-2
pitch
and a called strike three so a couple of
strikeouts
in the first big league inning for
trevor rogers
as seth lugo
makes a start for the first time since
2018.
john bertie first man to face him
and bernie takes outside corner strike
three called and lugo's got to strike
out and start his night alonzo over
three in the opener
they will check down at first and he
went around according to jansen visconti
so a third consecutive strikeout
for rogers and does a fantastic job of
elevating got back in the count couple
of off-speed pitches but then climb the
ladder with the fastball and you see
alonso is just tied up and the mets get
their first opportunity in this game
with a runner in scoring position 2-2
pitch bases loaded two outs in the
second rogers home with it and a swing
and a miss goes back to the fastball
he's got four strikeouts and two innings
brian anderson had two doubles in the
opener went two for three
and he strikes out anderson
second strikeout for seth who's retired
all four to start the night leigh when
diaz went one for three in the opener
and drove into runs
and the curve ball has luan diaz struck
out yeah you don't see curveballs like
that in double a very well
took a call third strike his first time
does it again dials up the heat my
goodness 95 up and in porto overmatched
strikeout number five
jesus sanchez went over three in the
opener now just one for 18 to start his
big league career 3-2 coming to sanchez
and he struck him out
four strikeouts for lugo eight up and
eight down for seth so two out of nobody
on that brian navaretto
on the outside corner got him looking a
perfect three innings for lugo he's got
five strikeouts
zanagiorme who drew a walk his first
time up will try and get that
first run of the day home
there's a call strike three
dials up 95 on the black his sixth
strikeout he continues to make pitches
on the edges after throwing a breaking
ball outside dials up 95 puts it right
on the corner first and third two outs
sanchez at the plates
that's in the air right center field
john bertie underneath it and rogers
works out of some trouble in the fourth
still scoreless bring up corey dickerson
that is hit hard and down the right
field line birdie is on his way to third
and he takes a big turn around third but
he'll stay put right there so another
hit for corey dickerson
and it's got the marlins set up nicely
here in the fourth now good piece of
hitting by dickerson golden opportunity
for the marlins to get the lead
and here's why
ba
three balls in the strike on the way
that one is hit fair down the left field
line that's going to go to the corner
and mcneil's got to chase this one down
rounding third and coming home cory
dickerson two runs will score it's
another double for brian anderson three
on the day and it's two nothing marlon
yeah great piece of hitting by brian
anderson here's conforto tying right at
the plate in a two-nothing game one-two
swinging a miss on a good breaking ball
conforto's punch down
smith fanning michael who struck out
three times in this game dominic smith
leading things off 2-2 coming
and dom hits a ground ball into the
shift
it comes up though on forsyth and smith
is safe how many times have we seen that
happen and a ball hit that hard you
can't come in and field it like and
charge it like it's a slow ground ball
that was a bullet
so now guillorme with the tying runs on
base and one out loosening
that's hit and leigh diaz gets to the
bag they double up lagarus and get out
of trouble in the sixth we get the time
run to bat with jd davis coming up
marlins baseball this year oh here we go
it's a ground ball to third one two
[Applause]
win